large retailers are quietly using
controversial facial recognition
technology in their stores to combat the
rise in violent theft and coordinated
attacks it's part of a larger push to
turn retailers existing security cameras
into more sophisticated artificial
intelligence surveillance systems which
can automatically identify people
license plates and other information
that can be used to alert store
employees of unfolding threats and
ultimately prosecute offenders
nearly 69 billion dollars worth of
products are stolen from u.s retailers
each year and the attacks are getting
increasingly violent and more
coordinated but facial recognition
technology is controversial as research
has shown it's often inaccurate when
identifying people of color in women why
is that
early versions of algorithms were
trained using images of celebrities that
skewed white and male the worst
technology has an error rate of up to 35
percent when scanning darker skinned
women but less than one percent with
lighter skinned men companies have been
working to address the racial bias and
between 2014 and 2018 facial recognition
software got 20 times better at
searching a database to find a matching
photograph however as of 2019 the
government found that some software
still misidentified african american and
asian people 10 to 100 times more often
than white men however facial
recognition companies actively market
their technology to retailers who use it
to help gather evidence on repeat
offenders before ultimately sharing it
with local law enforcement one thing
those companies aren't sharing though
the names of the stores using the
technology few stores want to admit
they're involved with facial recognition
fearful of backlash from shoppers rite
aid used the technology for nearly a
decade at hundreds of stores but stopped
after an investigation from reuters
pointed out that it used the software in
largely low-income non-white
neighborhoods others like target and
home depot have tested facial
recognition in the past but now say they
don't use it forbes was able to confirm
that macy's and at least 12 other major
retailers are using the technology
but as for which ones the companies keep
that information close to the vest but
some retailers are using other types of
video technology that's not as
controversial virtual security guards
have become increasingly popular during
the pandemic guards are stationed
remotely and can respond to various
alerts like motions detected by a
security camera in the parking lot at
1am by speaking directly to the
suspected intruder and alerting law
enforcement body cameras like the ones
worn by police officers are now being
adapted by security guards at retail
stores too
[Music]